thou shalt eat holy the rations
inspected found fit and provided for thy
use or barely many native foods contain
poisons more treacherous than a [ __ ]
warlord somebody once said the way to a
man's heart is through his stomach that
is everybody's butt McGillicuddy's he's
particular he doesn't like Vienna
sausage he doesn't realize he's in the
South Pacific he thinks he's in the
Brown Derby
hey I know mag it's monotonous the same
thing day after day but it's good food
and it's good for you but Mackel show
them how to get along on a South Pacific
island is a gourmet a gastronomical
Robinson Crusoe yeah they look like
bananas they peel like bananas but they
don't taste like bananas duvets you know
why because they're not bananas they're
planters and you can't eat them raw
what's this a native Victory Garden no
doubt carrots rutabagas turnips well
whatever they are they're sure beauties
hmm well kept well cultivated but these
boys are not just passing the time
they're passing the fertilizer and from
you know where while this sort of
fertilizer is very effective it produces
a lot more than just vegetables take a
look and you'll see what I mean
no see eight Namath oh boy
Apple yeah Mac Beach apples good huh but
you know what they do to you
well the juice contains an acid which
attacks a tissue and you have a chemical
reaction which results in a sort of a
hot foot or a rather a severe
inflammation of the well anyway it burns
the hell out of your tongue
that's the spirit Mac eat your K rations
and life max brains are still in his
stomach well heaven came to dinner look
Mac we're not complaining about your
manners and it's alright to be friendly
with the natives but their food is not
prepared in the most sanitary fashion
very often the food which they handle
and you're now backing away infested
with germs which are extremely difficult
to digest
oh cool oh pardon me
yeah we see you Mac this is what you've
been waiting for be back in a couple of
seconds you'll have that big turkey
dinner
yum yum roast turkey and cranberries and
oh here we go again
too bad Meg you missed the boat but then
we'll have Turkey again sometime but in
the meantime
you